a Saturday session for Bradford's Alpha
United juniors
full of the joy fun and energy the
Grassroots game should bring
but away from these pitches players here
as young as seven frequently on the
receiving end of racial abuse
abuse has now had a royal response
Prince William president of the Football
Association has written this letter to
the club for a private secretary his
Royal Highness was deeply concerned to
hear about some of the racism you and
others are alpha United Junior Football
Club have faced
racism and abuse has no place in our
society
abhorrent behavior of this nature must
stop now and all those responsible held
to account
the prince was particularly saddened to
hear about the effects this intolerable
action can have on those who are simply
wanting to play a game of football Alpha
United's chairman says since first
speaking out on Sky News he's been
contacted by dozens of other clubs
nationally probably about 40 clubs reach
out to us all sharing their experiences
of what's happened in our country
there's been quite a few as well and
obviously when we've been going out
obviously playing other teams who have
been a minority ethnic they've all said
the same thing I can't believe you've
done that or good on you guys West
riding fa said it strongly condemns
racism and will always do its utmost to
hold perpetrators to account
also states that despite their efforts
the club did not support their
investigation process
Alpha United dispute this claiming
they've provided the evidence needed
local MP Nasha has written to the fa
calling for Less slogans more action
if you've got a child being called a p
word and black b word and other names
not okay that is not okay for anybody in
society there is no place for racism and
we have made pledges and pledges and
pledges to show risk them the red card
where are those pledges when it comes to
Grassroots football but beyond debates
about governance our young people being
forced to deal with abuse
listen to what 11 year old ibrahima goes
through they confirming and they're like
okay you know some names and stuff like
that n-word in it and then I get a bit
frustrated with that so I get on subs
and stuff and then when I'm on service I
got frustrated by why did I come off
like he was the one who was saying this
stuff to me it's not nice
[Music]
he says he'll keep turning his
frustration into goals but his
experiences are a reminder
football is a long way from showing
racism the red car shingi marike Sky
News Bradford